[Musique]
bonjour philippe bonne
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france la
situation en somalie est elle comparable
selon vous à ce qui se passe en ce
moment en afghanistan
alors tout d'abord merci de m'accueillir
est comparable à certains égards oui
comme vous le savez le le mot talibans
signifie étudiant en langue pachtoune je
crois en ouzbek enfin et le maul shebab
ce sont les jeunes au-delà de cette
similitude sémantique il y avait
évidemment des similitudes et des
ressemblances en termes de régime de
régime
politico-religieux les terroristes
shebab appartiennent peu ou prou à la
même mouvance que la nébuleuse des
talibans pour mémoire d'ailleurs ben
laden avait des épouse somalienne il a
séjourné en somalie et comme vous l'avez
souligné dans dans
l'introduction les shebab métastases non
seulement dans le pays mais au delà de
leurs frontières puisque ils ont même
comme il des attentats et sont allés
perpétrer des exactions jusqu'au
mozambique ou que cette situation a des
caractéristiques assez similaires en
effet certains égards par rapport à
l'afghanistan et on a effectivement la
communauté internationale qui investit
des milliards de dollars on a également
la une présence militaire à celle de la
mission de l'union africaine en somalie
et pourtant la lutte contre l'islamisme
ne semble pas efficace comment est-ce
qu'on peut l'expliquer
alors de façon assez simple puis d'abord
vous perdez fait des milliards de
dollars ont été injectés dans ce pays
mais sans véritablement d'accompagnement
réelle sur le terrain
l'intervention militaire comme vous
l'avez indiqué et n'est pas une
intervention des nations unies ni
d'intervention américaine ou française
ou britannique c'est une intervention de
l'union africaine amisom africaine
micheline somalia et qui gère à dans un
mandat assez étroit qui est amanda
défensif essentiellement la situation
autant qu'elle le peut ces milliards de
dollars n'ont fait qu'une chose il fait
qu'accroître la corruption endémique
d'un des pays les plus corrompus du
monde est bien évidemment tous ces
grands fonctionnaires de nos grands pays
occidentaux qui ne sortent quasiment
jamais sur le terrain je vais
régulièrement en somalie avec happy
laden ferro qui est le candidat du
renouveau dans ce pays on ne voit jamais
reste dans l'espace sécurisé du camp de
l'amisom dans l'enceinte de l'aéroport
mais ces milliards de dollars ne font
qu'entretenir une corruption qui depuis
30 ans dans graine ce pays au delà de la
question du régime politico religieux
c'est une question très importante bien
évidemment il y a essentiellement cette
question de la corruption aujourd'hui
les élections en somalie ne sont pas en
dépit de ce qu'elles devraient être
selon la constitution des élections où
le peuple vote pour résumer les députés
sont plus ou moins choisis et désignés
par des chefs de clans et par des
représentants des gouvernements fédéraux
puisque c'est un état fédéral et ses
parlementaires ensuite élisent le
président à aucun moment la population
elle-même ne prend pas à l'élection est
donc une des premières choses à faire
c'est de changer ce régime de changer ce
régime corrompu de changer cette façon
d'appréhender le problème parce que
sinon ça fait 30 ans que ce pli est
quasiment guerre civile et on peut
continuer comme ça pendant très
longtemps vous parliez des politiques
occidentales
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une certaine
déconnexion du terrain vous didier que
finalement ils ne connaissent pas
vraiment le pays une question de
projection de valeurs aussi qui n'a rien
à voir avec avec la qui se passe
véritablement en somalie on l'a vu pour
le mali où l'afghanistan par exemple
oui les déconnexions absolue une grande
perte de compétences par exemple en
termes de renseignements alors
évidemment les grandes puissances
présentes travaille beaucoup sur des
renseignements électroniques
on utilise des interceptions l'utilisent
des drôles on utilise beaucoup de très
belles choses comme ça très performante
mais mais sur la question par exemple du
renseignement humain sur le terrain il y
a de moins en moins de compétences de
moins en moins de capacité et on ne peut
pas espérer et des api et y contribuer à
le faire évoluer essayez de de soutenir
les gens qui peuvent incarner un avenir
différent uniquement en restant à l'abri
dans un camp retranché où derrière une
console d'ordinateurs à des centaines de
kilomètres c'est
l'aide internationale est finalement
très abstraite elle est concrète parce
qu'elle est détournée par
beaucoup de
gens du gouvernement par beaucoup de
gens des des tribus mais mais elle n'a
pas absolument rien à la population sur
le terrain rien du tout vous vous le
disiez il ya la lutte comme contre la
corruption comme priorité mais pour
éviter un scénario à vous quand comment
quelles solutions au niveau local par
exemple ça doit venir de l'intérieur du
terrain
alors d'une part il semble que le mandat
de l'amisom
l'african michel in somalia donc le
mandat de l'union africaine il me semble
qu'il est il et il est bien qu est
réparé par nos amis africains il
pourrait l'être encore mieux sans doute
puisque c'est un mandat qui est un peu
restrictif il devrait sans doute pouvoir
disposer d'un aspect plus offensif pour
lutter plus efficacement contre les
shebab c'est actuellement monsieur
tshisekedi qu'est le président en charge
de l'union africaine à partir du mois de
janvier ce sera le président du sénégal
macky sall qui va être
président de l'union africaine pour une
année
c'est que c'est un homme d'engagement de
conviction de décision j'espère que plus
ça permettra à ce mandat d'évoluer dans
de bonnes conditions parce que c'est
encore le dernier élément qui maintient
le pays un tout petit peu en état si
j'ose dire mais il faut absolument force
et
j'allais dire le monde politique
somalien à faire évoluer le mode de
scrutin faire évoluer le mode de
gouvernance les gens aspirent à cela
faut pas se tromper et notamment toute
la jeune génération qui en a assez de
vivre dans un pays où il est absolument
aucune et sans aucun espoir de
développement et le mot corruption c'est
le mot clé il faut aller vers les
radiales l'éradication de cette
corruption or le système institutionnel
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui ne fait que
permettra à cette scop gens des milk de
perdurer merci beaucoup philippe bohn de
votre éclairage merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions ce matin en direct sur
arte france